The year was 2002.
America was just a few months out of 9/11.
We were at war in Afghanistan, and at war
against an abstract concept called “terror.”
The news was full of anthrax attacks, shoe
bombers, and nuclear weapons.
With the whole country obsessed with terrorism,
George Bush was one of the most popular presidents
in history.
But there was a problem.
Even though huge resources had already been
expended, none of the terrorist leaders—people
like Osama bin Laden or Khalid Sheikh Mohammed—had
been found.
And Americans were looking for blood.
But in March of 2002, after months of waiting,
that finally changed.
The U.S. got its guy.
No, not Osama.
And not Khalid Sheikh Mohammed.
But he was still really, really important.
You see, for months the CIA had been talking
about this one guy.
His name was Zayn al-Abedin Muhammad Hussein
– more commonly known as “ABU ZUBAYDAH.”
According to the CIA, this “Abu Zubaydah”
was one of the most fearsome terrorists in
the entire world.
He was born in Palestine, but he had gone
to Afghanistan in the eighties to fight the
Soviets.
And after the war, he stayed in Afghanistan,
becoming the manager of a terrorist training
camp, and the chief of operations for all
of al-Qaeda, and a top lieutenant to Osama
bin Laden.
So Abu Zubaydah was a really big fish.
CNN reported that Abu Zubaydah might have
actually been controlling al-Qaeda himself.
Based on that information, the U.S. approached
the government of Pakistan, a country to Afghanistan’s
east, and offered ten million dollars if they
helped find this mysterious bad guy.
So the Americans did raid after raid in Pakistan,
looking for Abu Zubaydah.
After several attempts, they finally found
the guy in a safe house.
During the raid, however, he was shot several
times in the head, suffering severe injuries—so
severe the CIA flew a doctor from Johns Hopkins
into Pakistan to keep the suspect alive.
Once it was clear that he would live, the
CIA took custody of him.
In America, this was announced as huge news.
“Among those we have captured is a man named
Abu Zubaydah, al Qaeda’s chief of operations.
From him, and from hundreds of others, we
are learning more about how the terrorists
plan and operate; information crucial in anticipating
and preventing future attacks.
Our coalition is strong.”
But back in Pakistan, the people who were
detaining him discovered something disturbing.
Abu Zubaydah was not exactly the guy they
thought he was.
You see, while he was fighting in Afghanistan,
Zubaydah was hit in the head by some shrapnel.
Some of that shrapnel lodged in his brain,
and gave him serious brain damage.
He developed severe memory problems, and couldn’t
speak for a year.
So the man they had arrested was not a “senior
al-Qaeda operative.”
He wasn’t a senior operative in ANYTHING.
He was a greeter in a training camp in Afghanistan,
but it was not an al-Qaeda camp—it was opposed
to al-Qaeda.
The CIA had even helped set it up in the eighties.
When the government found Abu Zubaydah’s
diary—thousands of pages long, recording
minute details of people he met or what he
ate every day—they found nothing relating
to the terrorist attacks in which he was allegedly
involved.
What they found instead was the story of a
mentally ill individual, whose head injury
resulted in his writing the diary in any one
of three different personalities.
The FBI’s senior expert on al-Qaeda said
himself: “This guy is insane, certifiable,
split personality.”
The diaries showed that Abu Zubaydah simply
wasn’t involved in al-Qaeda.
He wrote more about his deep attachment to
his mother than about any involvement in terrorist
activities.
Here’s one diary entry.
“Now, I don’t cry when I remember my dad
beating up my mom.
… I don’t cry when I remember her crying
like a child in my arms when I was a child;
I don’t cry when I remember all these things
as much as I cry when I remember that I offended
her.”
This was not exactly the “master terrorist”
the U.S. thought they had captured.
But the U.S. government had already said,
very publicly, that this guy was a top operative
in al-Qaeda and a trusted confidante of Osama
bin Laden.
So in April 2002, President Bush turned to
his CIA director and told him, “I said he
was important.
You’re not going to let me lose face on
this, are you?”
The CIA director responded that no, he wouldn’t
let the president lose face.
So what was initially a MISTAKE, was declared
to be true—and became a FABRICATION.
Abu Zubaydah became the first “high-value
detainee” of the War on Terror.
Two weeks after his capture, he was transported
to a “black site” in Thailand, where he
could be subject to a new method of interrogation
the CIA was testing out.
Almost immediately after Abu Zubaydah was
captured, the CIA began discussing how to
interpret the U.S.’s prohibition on torture
in order to allow for what they called “enhanced
interrogation.”
And at the black site, they put that plan
into effect.
Here’s how a government report described
the atmosphere of the prison.
“A cable described Abu Zubaydah's cell as
white with no natural lighting or windows,
but with four halogen lights pointed into
the cell.
Security officers wore all black uniforms,
including boots, gloves, balaclavas, and goggles
to keep Abu Zubaydah from identifying the
officers, as well as to prevent Abu Zubaydah
‘from seeing the security guards as individuals
who he may attempt to establish a relationship
or dialogue with.’
The security officers communicated by hand
signals when they were with Abu Zubaydah and
used handcuffs and leg shackles to maintain
control.
In addition, either loud rock music was played
or noise generators were used to enhance Abu
Zubaydah’s ‘sense of hopelessness.’
Abu Zubaydah was typically kept naked and
sleep deprived.”
During his time in Thailand, Zubaydah was
kept in terrible conditions.
At the beginning, he was given no solid food,
and kept naked and shackled to a chair.
After a few weeks, he was given rice once
a day, and allowed to sleep naked on the floor.
Zubaydah was kept totally isolated for an
entire month while the CIA developed a plan
for more aggressive torture.
In late July, they began testing a procedure
called “WATERBOARDING,” in which a prisoner
would be strapped to a table with water poured
over their head, in order to simulate the
experience of drowning.
In August 2002 alone, Abu Zubaydah was waterboarded
83 times.
On one occasion, his interrogators continued
the torture for too long, nearly drowning
Abu Zubaydah.
For seventeen straight days, the CIA used
a variety of techniques: waterboarding, slamming
him against a concrete wall, confining him
in a small box, depriving him of sleep, blasting
white noise, and keeping him in a freezing
room.
As the torture continued, Abu Zubaydah became
so broken and compliant that when an interrogator
snapped his finger twice, Abu Zubaydah would
lie down flat to be waterboarded.
In at least one session, he became completely
unresponsive, totally desensitized to the
torture.
All of this was filmed by the CIA, and ninety-two
tapes were produced of what was done in Thailand.
But while they were torturing Zubaydah, the
CIA began to find that he wasn’t really
able to provide them much information.
The CIA still thought he was holding back.
So they continued torturing him.
In order to prevent further torture, Zubaydah
told them what they wanted to hear.
So Zubaydah told them that al-Qaeda wanted
to attack the Brooklyn Bridge and the Statue
of Liberty, and that they knew how to build
a nuclear weapon and smuggle it into America.
He even told them that al-Qaeda had ties to
Saddam Hussein’s government in Iraq.
All of these false statements were used by
the Bush administration to justify expanding
the War on Terror.
Abu Zubaydah’s statements were a big part
of the intelligence that America cited in
invading Iraq the next year.
But what Zubaydah was telling his torturers
was never actually useful.
According to the Washington Post, “not a
single significant plot was foiled as a result
of Abu Zubaydah’s tortured confessions.”
Soon the CIA began to have doubts about the
information Abu Zubaydah was providing, and
about their methods in getting that information.
Some of them even requested that if Zubaydah
died during interrogation, his body be cremated
so that the torture wouldn’t be discovered.
So in 2005, a CIA agent named Gina Haspel—the
person who oversaw the black site in Thailand—ordered
the destruction of ninety videotapes of Zubaydah’s
torture.
In September 2006, Zubaydah left CIA custody
and was transferred to Guantanamo Bay, America’s
main detention camp for “enemy combatants.”
By then, the CIA had already concluded that
Zubaydah was, in fact, not even a member of
al-Qaeda.
By the time that Zubaydah arrived in Guantanamo,
the torture had fully broken him.
And that was more than a decade ago.
To this day, Zubaydah is still in captivity
in Guantanamo, the country that tortured him
having simply forgotten about him.
It never mattered that they knew he was innocent.
Just look at what happened to the people who
tortured Zubaydah.
Gina Haspel, who oversaw Zubaydah’s torture,
became director of the CIA in 2018.
President Bush retired to his ranch in Texas.
And Abu Zubaydah, meanwhile, is still in Guantanamo
Bay.
He has never been charged with anything.
More than ten years after the government concluded
he wasn’t a terrorist, he’s still held
in strict detention.
“My mother,” he said in one letter to
the outside world.
“I have not seen her in so long.”
I’m Ismael Loutfi, for the Gravel Institute.